in this video we witness a dad teaching
a mother a very valuable lesson now I'm
aware that this video upset a lot of
people but before I give you my thoughts
on it I I want you guys to to take a
look and get your initial feeling of the
video first and then I'll let you know
what I think so let's check
out
[Music]
yeah
so I think that speaks to the state of
our culture right now she is so
distracted by her phone that she's not
even aware of her surroundings she's not
aware what's going on including the fact
that her child is within her
surroundings and they're out in public
at night you really shouldn't be facing
away from your
child looking in your phone I think we
can all agree hopefully on that point
what now I think the issue here a lot of
people have is whether it was kind for
the dad to do this to her and put her
through this emotional
distress look I think it's great I
completely agree with what he did is a
valuable lesson and
unfortunately as human beings we tend to
only learn things through action right
when you're a kid if you touch the hot
stove you're not going to touch it again
because you've already touched it you
know we have this curiosity and it's
only through that Curiosity that we can
learn things and that's only through
action you know using the stove example
a mother could say to a child a million
times don't touch the stove it's hot
you're going to get hurt you're going to
get hurt but really it's only when the
child touches the hot stove and they
actually have that experience of ow that
hurts that they're never they're
definitely never going to touch that hot
stove again I actually had a similar
experience when I was a kid for
Christmas I got some money and I left
the money lying around somewhere and my
cousin took the money and sort of
pretended that it was stolen or whatever
and I I panicked I'm like where's the
money gone and I had the same reaction
as this lady I'm looking around and I'm
completely lost and then my cousin pulls
out the money he like don't leave your
money lying around and you know what it
was a great lesson I've never left my
money lying around since soon as I get
any kind of money in a gift or whatever
it goes straight in my purse and my
purse goes in my bag and I think that's
just an example of how
experiences shape our Behavior more than
anything else because her husband May
well we don't know the context here we
don't know the history behind this her
husband May well have told her before
you need to be more aware of your
surroundings you need to be more aware
of what's going on around you especially
when you're looking after our baby and
this may have happened well before this
incident and this incident may be the
peak of some ongoing story that we
perhaps don't know about I'm speculating
I could be completely wrong either way
even if this was the first instance of
this I completely agree with what he's
done I think it's absolutely necessary I
actually think it's appalling that she
could be so engrossed with something
that's going on on her screen to not
even realize that her own child is being
taken
away even after she realized that the
child's gone notice what she's still
holding on to she doesn't drop the phone
I think there's a very valuable lesson
for us to learn here about how addicted
we are to these things and how important
they've become in our lives that even
when a woman has lost her child the
child has been seemingly kidnapped
that's that's still she's still clinging
on to that it's the fact that even as
soon as she realized the child is gone
the first place she checked is the
little I don't know what it's called but
the little flap thing like like the
child's going to be in there it's like
her brain isn't even working logically
and she doesn't know what to do with
herself she's just sort of looking
around completely lost because her
attention was elsewhere and she just
doesn't know what to do so
look the only way for us to really learn
unfortunately a lot of the time is the
hard way and that's through experience
it's through action and I think the
husband has done
an absolutely great job here of teaching
her a very valuable lesson and hopefully
she takes that lesson on board and she
becomes more aware of her surroundings
and she knows when to put the phone down
and realize where you are and to be a
bit more aware and have more attention
on your child than you do on a piece of
metal in your hand